shannon what we're seeing right now is a
full-scale invasion i spoke to a u.s
official tonight when the initial uh
missiles began
striking these various cities in ukraine
and i was told that we are seeing
pre-assault fires we can expect this to
go on for a few hours
then this will be followed by a land
attack and i was told by a senior u.s
official that
who's monitoring the situation right now
that you can expect all of the full
forces of vladimir putin that he's
arrayed uh to then enter into ukraine so
this is the beginning of a very serious
full-scale
invasion that will be followed by a land
assault
you're seeing these pre-assault fires
these are ballistic missiles they're
cruise missiles you will expect to hear
um
it will be followed by artillery
they are taking out command and control
sites
this is something i would not be
surprised to be seeing waves of of of
air
air assault uh to begin at any time it's
a little surprising that they're doing
this in
at first light you would expect
something like this to be done overnight
um but it's clear vladimir putin wants
the world to see what he is doing what
struck me by his from his speech tonight
was the chilling words that he used when
he started talking about demilitarizing
and denotifying
ukraine supposedly
there have been videos all day of nazis
being playing on russian state
television uh the way that in which
putin is describing ukraine he's
describing it as an existential threat
to russia this is a figment of his
imagination this is a man if you look in
his eyes this is somebody who has gone
completely mad what we are seeing
tonight is
a moment in history something we have
not seen for generations war on the
continent of europe a
sovereign country being invaded by a
nuclear power one of the reasons that
the president of course is not sending
u.s troops or uh promising any sort of
air flights over uh over ukraine to
defend uh ukraine is because you're
talking about a nuclear power uh the us
and nato are not going to go to war with
a nuclear power
but they are going to support the
ukrainians the ukrainians are going to
fight i thought the lindsay's speech
tonight the president was noble he he
you know many people doubted this
president zielinski and and wondered
whether he would flee in the and and the
way ashok ghani did from afghanistan
this was a noble noble speech tonight
from this former comedian nate the late
night host who is now the president of a
nation that is being invaded
by a nuclear power yeah you saw the deep
passion and commitment from him and the
urgency and what he was saying tonight
jennifer you also flagged a little bit
earlier tonight some of what putin had
to say he says
a couple of words for those who would be
tempted to intervene russia will respond
immediately and you will have
consequences that you never have had
before in your history is that to the
u.s
this is a direct message to the u.s and
nato one of the reasons you see 11
that putin has put so many of his
surface warships in the black sea uh 11
you have not only amphibious landing
ships though it is possible he could use
those for marines to come in and take
odessa but you also it is to send a
signal uh those warships those russian
warships in the black sea have cruise
missiles on them they are uh they are
there to tell nato don't try to send any
warships don't move closer remember we
have the uss harry s truman uh near
italy we have uh positioned there are
some submarines of carrying out
exercises this week this but but
putin would be misreading nato and the
us
the us has been very calibrated in
making sure that it is bolstering its
article five nato allies in the baltics
poland lithuania the baltics as well as
romania but not to provoke putin by
putting excessive numbers of forces
there that would then justify what we
are seeing tonight in terms of this
invasion into this this war against
ukraine and jennifer while i have you uh
nato's secretary general also putting
out a statement tonight condemning what
russia has done saying we're going to
stick together it says we stand with the
people of ukraine at this terrible time
nato will do all it takes to protect and
defend all allies of course that doesn't
include ukraine that was one of the
sticking points with putin who wanted a
guarantee that ukraine would never be a
part of nato
but while this is confined to a country
for now that does not have an article 5
obligation
how closely now is is nato drawn into
this you know potential conflict which
we hope does not broaden any further
well i think you have to listen when you
have a madman like putin who is making
the kind of statements and revising
history the way he has in in uh his
recent speeches you have to look at what
he's saying because leaders like this
they say uh what they're going to do
they telegraph their punches and so if
in in the speech the the written speech
that he uh wrote last july and sent out
to his armed forces justifying this uh
this uh invasion of ukraine he also
mentioned quite worrisome and this is
something that u.s intelligence is
watching closely uh he's mentioned
poland he mentioned lithuania and the
the history
of those countries
that should be
of concern to anyone in europe tonight
and anyone uh in nato because uh poland
there's a very worrisome you know
right now
putin has about 30 000 forces inside
belarus nobody's talking about how
basically belarus has become a vassal
state of of putin he's already extended
the borders of russia
in terms of the way he's he's positioned
his forces in belarus and that is just
across the border from poland and that
is why the u.s sent the 82nd airborne
and other uh forces to to reassure
the eastern flank of nato but this is
once you start a war like putin has
started tonight you start on an
escalation ladder and you don't know
there are unintended consequences and
what we don't know is how this ends
jennifer griffin thank you very much we
will check back in with you as this
continues to play out hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else